there is never a bad time to start a  great business  people are going to start getting scared  and a lot of you are not going to do a  business because you're like [ __ ] the  economy I don't want to give up this job  I just want to let the one percent know  this one percent that has true  conviction has a great idea and is  really actually ready and has enough  savings to get through the storm if it  fails even in a recession there is never  a bad time to start a great business  some of the greatest businesses of all  time have been started pouring down  economic periods so  sure this is a time to get practical and  be a little safer for many the people  that are kind of wavering aren't 100  about that but if you were 110 about it  and you're actually ready and you're  either in a place where you can afford  it because you're a youngster or you've  got some savings and you can go for it  great businesses can start at any time